when you've got it all working then go
ahead and extend the code add a function
greet by period that takes a name and a
period or a period the time of day like
morning afternoon evening and return a
hello class object whose greeting field
includes a greeting using the name in
the period for example if the name is
Kippy in the period is morning the
message in the hello class would be good
morning Kippy and if the name was Ken
and the period was evening the message
would be good evening can add this
endpoints API function to your app try
it out in the api's explorer an update
index dot HTML to allow people to call
this function from the UI so just a
reminder that to go to the api's
explorer you go to slash underscore aah
slash API slash Explorer and when you've
got your app working and it's got this
new function this function must have
this exact name because we're going to
test it and if you use a different name
our tests won't work go ahead and enter
your app ID here